saludos en este vídeo vamos a deducir
esta fórmula que es la fórmula de la
frecuencia de pulsación recordemos que
la forma de encontrar los pulsos o la
frecuencia de pulsación es superponer
dos ondas que tienen frecuencias
diferentes con esto encontramos los
pulsos y no me refiero a los pulsos
cardiacos estos son un poco menos
emocionantes sino que es una onda de
sonido que pasa de escucharse fuerte es
decir cuando tiene interferencia
constructiva a escucharse suave cuando
tiene interferencia destructiva y de
nuevo pasa a escucharse fuerte cuando la
interferencia vuelve a ser constructiva
el número de veces por segundo que
ocurre esto es la frecuencia de
pulsación el número de oscilaciones por
segundo es la frecuencia de pulsación y
la forma de calcular esto es encontrar
la diferencia de las frecuencias
individuales de las ondas de sonido que
se superponen pero porque es ésta la
fórmula porque no es más complicada esto
es justamente lo que responderemos en
este vídeo la forma en que lo haremos es
encontrar primero el periodo de
pulsación de esta onda si la frecuencia
de pulsación es el número de
oscilaciones por segundo
entonces el periodo de pulsación es el
número de segundos por oscilación en
otras palabras que tanto tiempo le toma
a este proceso pasar de ser constructivo
a volver a ser constructivo porque si
encontramos esto el periodo de pulsación
encontraremos la frecuencia pues sabemos
que la frecuencia es el inverso del
periodo si encontramos el periodo
dividimos uno entre este valor y
tendremos la frecuencia de pulsación
como encontramos el periodo de pulsación
lo encontramos al observar que este
período de pulsación es el tiempo que le
toma a estas ondas desplazarse de tal
forma que sus picos o crestas se
superpongan en un momento y luego se
vuelvan a superponer en un momento
posterior vamos a quitar esto y a ver
las ondas individualmente suponiendo que
ambas ondas comienzan en fase y con
interferencia constructiva queremos
saber cuánto tiempo pasa hasta que su
interferencia vuelva a ser constructiva
nos interesa este tiempo vamos a
encontrar esto detectando cuando estas
ondas están en fase y cada vez que la
onda roja
un periodo estar a esta distancia
adelante de la onda azul con esto me
refiero a que la cresta roja ocurre esta
fracción de tiempo después de que ocurre
la cresta azul estas crestas están fuera
de fase esta cantidad y cuál es esta
cantidad pues es la diferencia entre los
periodos de estas dos ondas es la
diferencia del periodo de la onda roja
que llamaremos la onda 1 y la onda azul
que llamaremos onda 2 de esta forma no
tendremos números negativos porque el
periodo de la onda 1 es más largo que el
periodo de la onda 2 esta diferencia es
que tan fuera de fase en el tiempo se
encuentran las crestas de estas dos
ondas si esperamos un ciclo estarán
desfasadas exactamente esta cantidad de
tiempo si esperamos dos ciclos el
desfase de tiempo será el doble de esta
cantidad si esperamos tres ciclos
estarán desfasadas tres veces esta
cantidad en que nos ayuda a esto pues si
queremos saber qué tan separadas están
estas crestas en cualquier momento del
tiempo vamos a tomar esta diferencia del
periodo y la multiplicamos por el número
de ciclos que ha recorrido
onda roja si la onda roja recorrió tres
ciclos sustituyo tres acá y el triple de
esta diferencia nos dará la separación
en el tiempo que tienen estas crestas lo
escribimos que están separadas en el
tiempo están las crestas las crestas
inician estando juntas después del
primer ciclo están separadas esta
cantidad después de dos ciclos están
separadas esta otra cantidad y después
de tres ciclos están separadas
esta cantidad después de cuatro ciclos
es esta cantidad y después de cinco
ciclos es esta cantidad ahora las
crestas están separándose en fase tanto
que la siguiente que está roja se
superpone con la siguiente cresta azul
es decir que la onda azul ha avanzado lo
suficiente en el tiempo durante estos
ciclos como para que su siguiente cresta
se superponga con esta cresta roja es en
este momento cuando vuelve a ocurrir una
interferencia constructiva esta es la
condición para volver a tener una
interferencia constructiva que la onda
roja esté tan desfasada como para
completar todo un periodo de la onda
azul de manera que se vuelve a
superponer con la cresta de la onda azul
si queremos conocer el tiempo que pasa
entre una interferencia constructiva y
la siguiente interferencia constructiva
será cuando haya pasado el tiempo
necesario para recorrer la distancia que
separa estas dos crestas es decir cuando
sea igual a todo un período de la
segunda onda cuando esto se cumple
entonces sabemos que ha pasado el tiempo
suficiente para que ambas ondas tengan
de nuevo interferencia constructiva ya
que la onda azul ha adelantado lo
suficiente como para coincidir de nuevo
con la cresta de la onda roja pero quizá
a ustedes les llame la atención que en
esta expresión no está la variable
tiempo como pueden encontrar el tiempo
cuando aquí no hay ninguna referencia al
tiempo aquí solamente hay esta constante
estate azul o t2 es una constante
determinada por el periodo de la onda
azul lo mismo ocurre con té roja como
podemos encontrar el tiempo aquí el
número de ciclos que ha recorrido la
onda roja no es necesariamente un número
entero en este ejemplo la onda roja
recorre exactamente
dos tres cuatro cinco y seis ciclos de
la onda azul antes de volver a estar en
fase con esta onda pero esto no siempre
sucede esto lo hice a propósito para que
se apreciará con claridad cuando las
ondas se vuelven a alinear pero quizá
esto no es un número entero quizá esto
ocurre después de 4.2 ciclos o 3.1
ciclos sería bueno tener una forma
general de escribir la cantidad de
ciclos recorridos por la onda roja y si
la hay el número de ciclos recorridos
por la onda roja es igual al tiempo que
esperamos dividido entre el periodo de
la onda roja que llamamos periodo 1 esto
tiene sentido porque si esperamos un
ciclo completo 1 entonces 1 entre un
periodo es igual a un ciclo completo de
la onda roja si pasaron dos periodos
aquí tendremos dos por t 1 entre t 1 las
t 1 se cancelan y nos quedan dos ciclos
con esto podemos escribir el número de
ciclos que ha recorrido la onda roja
como una función del tiempo que haya
sido necesario para que esto ocurra
ahora podemos poner el tiempo cuando no
tenga
un número entero de ciclos podemos poner
cuántos ciclos ha recorrido la onda roja
a los 4.3 segundos los 4.3 segundos los
dividimos entre el periodo de la onda
roja que es el tiempo que tarda en
recorrer un ciclo completo y nos da como
resultado el número de ciclos recorridos
por la onda roja vamos a reemplazar esta
n r con esta otra expresión la copiamos
la pegamos y reescribimos n r como el
tiempo de espera entre el periodo de la
onda roja ahora solo tenemos que
despejar la t minúscula para saber el
tiempo que le tomó a estas dos ondas
desfasarse durante un periodo completo
de la segunda onda lo que es la
condición para que ambas ondas pasen de
una interferencia constructiva a otra
interferencia constructiva que es lo que
estamos buscando el periodo de pulsación
si despejamos de minúscula el tiempo
necesario para que los picos de estas
dos ondas vuelvan a estar en fase va a
ser igual multiplicamos ambos lados por
t 1 y nos queda t minúscula igual a tf1
por t 2 /
este término en paréntesis de 1 menos de
2 este es el período de pulsación porque
cumple con la condición de que estarán
separadas un periodo completo de la onda
2 y si comenzaron en fase terminarán en
fase después de este tiempo que es el
tiempo entre puntos de interferencia
constructiva este es el período de
pulsación lo copiamos aquí es el periodo
de pulsación entre ambas ondas pero
recordemos que no buscamos el periodo de
pulsación sino la frecuencia de
pulsación es decir deducir esta fórmula
vamos a hacer un poco de espacio para
encontrar la frecuencia dividimos uno
entre el periodo uno entre el periodo de
pulsación es igual a uno entre el lado
derecho lo que da la diferencia entre
los periodos dividida entre el producto
de los periodos simplemente invertimos
el lado derecho y ahora desarrollamos
este término de uno entre t 1 por t 2
menos de 2 entre t 1 por t 2 y ahora
ocurre algo mágico se cancelan las t 1
de aquí y se cancelan las t 2 de acá por
lo que nos queda que el inverso del
periodo de pulsación
al inverso del periodo de la onda 2 - el
inverso del periodo de la onda 1 a que
es igual el inverso del periodo de
pulsación pues es la frecuencia de
pulsación ya que es igual el inverso del
periodo de la onda 2 adivinaron es la
frecuencia de la onda 2a que es igual el
universo del periodo de la onda 1 pues a
la frecuencia de la onda 1 y ya tenemos
la fórmula de la frecuencia de pulsación
que es la fórmula que queríamos
encontrar por lo que ya dijimos lo que
queríamos la razón es porque tuvimos que
esperar exactamente este tiempo del
periodo de pulsación para que las
crestas de las ondas estuvieran de nuevo
en fase tenemos que esperar que las
ondas se desfasen un periodo completo de
la segunda onda para volver a estar en
fase y ustedes me pueden decir que hace
falta el valor absoluto aquí aunque el
inicio del vídeo tuvimos el cuidado de
poner la onda con el periodo más largo y
restarle la onda con el periodo más
pequeño para así asegurarnos de que el
resultado fuera un número positivo pero
ponemos los valores absolutos en caso de
que no sepamos cuál onda tiene el
periodo más largo y cuál es el periodo
más pequeño
de esta manera determinamos la
frecuencia
pulsación y ahora ya sabemos por qué
esta fórmula es así nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo